before we get to anything
i have some i have something to tell you
judd apatow told me um that and i want
to know if it's true
he told me that it's your fault that
people scream my name
everywhere i go
ah kelly clarkson everywhere i go i
could literally do anything and it
doesn't matter how many hits
what i do in life i could save a family
from drowning fires i could do anything
and literally the one thing people know
me from is
ah kelly clarkson
yeah so is this true
well i'm i'm terribly sorry first of all
i know you uh i owe you an apology no
it's awesome
[Laughter]
it is true yes that is true it was um i
was a co-producer on on the
four-year-old version i was also in it
but um it was i was a writer mostly by
trade at the time um so i was hired to
write also like uh jokes we call them
alt jokes or alternate jokes um and we
knew corel was going to be waxed and he
wouldn't be able to think clearly
probably so we wanted to just be able to
feed him things to say and we don't
always like to only have profanity so uh
judd was like you should write a list of
jokes that are like uh dirty jokes like
and and a list of clean jokes
um and it was hard to write the clean
jokes um and
i
honestly think i was sitting on my couch
writing the jokes and you came on
television and i saw you
and
it was kelly clarkson and in comedy
there's a thing with like cur sounds
like they say like comedy k like like a
k sound is is known for being funny in
in the comedy world and so i saw your
name and it was kelly clarkson and there
it was and there's an action i'm in
between
burger panties
and throbbing monkey tail
i like it how much of that list just has
to be completely blurred out because
you see i stuck to the assignment though
really of doing what half of clean
jumpsuit would have dirty
i am just saying i loved it so much i
did actually i literally was coming into
a theater how i first heard it was in a
preview i was coming into a theater to
watch a different movie and i was with
friends we were late because you know i
gotta hit up concessions for some
popcorn m m's and so we came in a little
late and we were like coming in and i
was like and everybody was like and i
thought somebody in the theater yelled
my name i didn't know what just happened
because i was like what and that's how i
found out they were like they yelled
your name in that trailer and i was like
why and then i was like anyway and it's
literally i can be i can be in japan it
doesn't matter where the hell i am steph
people since you've been gone never
heard of it but kelly clarkson's name
being yelled during a waxing that's what
they know it's amazing
[Music]
you